across the capitol
across the nation
silence
a moment to reflect for the people
and their new king
[Applause]
he was issued this statement on the eve
of his mother's funeral
as we all prepared to say our last
farewell he said i wanted simply to take
this opportunity to say thank you to all
those countless people who've been such
a support and comfort to my family
and myself and this time of grief
the happy more extraordinary scenes in
westminster hall
ordinary mourners joined by a stream of
foreign dignitaries
the kings of spain and
sweden the first lady of ukraine clearly
moved and presidents from around the
world
u.s president joe biden joining mourners
to pay his respects
she was the same in person as her image
decent honorable
and all about service it's a loss that
leaves a giant hole
and uh
sometimes you think you'll never
you'll never overcome it but
as i've told the king
she's going to be with him every step of
the way every minute every moment
and that's a reassuring notion
one of a hundred heads of governments
gathering here from emperors to crown
princes there are 20 royals among 500
foreign guests
the prime minister of that team
they know this will never be repeated
because a unique era is drawing to a
close
another beginning not least for the
commonwealth whose leaders met king
charles earlier today
on the eve of the funeral a prediction
from the president of trinidad and
tobago that under the new king more and
more commonwealth countries will give up
the monarch as head of state as the
times continue changing
there is a feeling now after all these
years that the sovereign should really
be the people
and that to have a sovereign from a
country that is far removed
not only geographically but culturally
right might not necessarily be the best
thing at this time of the nation's
development
so i think that perhaps the process will
begin speeding up
in various territories
what would be your emotions
what will be going through your
your mind as you sit in the abbey
tomorrow looking back on the era
i thought well i really would have to
carry my handkerchief with me because
it's quite possible
that i may shed a tear
for the queen
at this funeral death will be the great
leveler whatever the rank dignitaries
all arriving in coach class bust in from
chelsea's royal hospital
being corralled in a glorified holding
pen and then put on buses is not what
world leaders are used to but it is the
only option say officials who've never
had to deal with so many foreign
dignitaries all at the same time
barters leaders and dignitaries filed
into buckingham palace this evening a
sense of the enormity of this occasion
the world's most influential and
powerful people gathering together to
pay a final tribute
to a monarch loved like no other
dominic waghorn sky news westminster